why couldn't we get enough masks why
couldn't we get enough fin lighters why
weren't there the perception that there
weren't enough hospital beds how come
the morgues couldn't keep up and so on
and so on how come we couldn't be
prepared for this and no matter how you
look at it at every area it was a
failure of government as a liberty
minded person as you said if people
don't come out of this more libertarian
something will have gone wrong what what
are the the proper approaches for a
liberty minded government so say a
libertarian or classical liberal set of
ideas that could get us through
something like this what should we have
done sort of at the beginning what
should we have done as we're going
through it right now and what should we
be looking at for the future if you want
to keep people as free as possible while
also dealing with something that we've
never dealt with before David were going
to summarize my position in a sentence
it would be something like this the
medical professionals in the medical
industry free of all restrictions should
have been allowed to deal with this
virus from the very beginning without
the intervention of politicians period I
mean that that basically just get rid of
red tape just let them do their thing no
more no more regulations on experimental
treatments that kind of stuff yeah and
not only that but you know if you think
about it Dave a lot of this flattened
the curve analysis that led to the
crackdowns and they've mandatory social
distancing and and the universal house
imprisonment that we're dealing with
right now was due to the perception that
the medical industry was unscalable in
the event of emergency now that's very
interesting you people need to be asked
question if it's true
why was an industry unable to scale
industry is specialized in scaling you
know when when people buy more of your
product as an industry you're excited to
for more of that product or service to
them what makes the medical industry
unique in that respect
why couldn't we get enough masks why
couldn't we get enough ventilators
why weren't there the perception that
there weren't enough hospital beds how
come the morgues couldn't keep up and so
on and so on how come we couldn't be
prepared for this and no matter how you
look at it at every area it was a
failure of government it was the system
was was was heavily regulated the
Strategic Medical Reserve
disincentivized hospitals from it from
gathering their own supplies the tariffs
on masks seriously inhibited and this is
very personal to me because I I have
friends in New York who are nurses and
doctors who are sharing masks I can't
get enough and the tariffs seriously
injured that and the hospitals didn't
have enough supplies on hand because
they assumed that it was all there the
federal government was putting it all
together but then of course they opened
the warehouse and the hash validators
don't work you know the the supplies
aren't there because they had previously
been depleted every area all you see is
government irrationality the inability
of hospitals to scale the panic of the
political class to force everybody into
their homes which is definitely where
you should not be whether you have
respiratory disease the poor the answer
is to get outside as everybody
understands you don't want to put old
people with young people because that
causes endless amounts of infections you
actually want to isolate and separate
the people who are vulnerable to this
disease which are the old and and fail
and and the last thing you want to do is
close the schools because Cove it as we
know now is is it was actually not fatal
for young healthy people so at every
single area Dave's the government has
done the wrong thing and I don't know
how long or how detailed we want to get
here but the testing Fiasco was the
great I would say beginning of all this
stuff because China had already gone
through a trial run of this stuff you
know we had this benefit of this we saw
this coming and the CDC in the FDA
stopped in this is a matter of record I
really stopped private researchers from
developing the test and distributing the
test from the very beginning of this
crisis that was a catastrophic thing and
that led to what I've called an
epistemic crisis we didn't know we
didn't know who had it whether I had it
whether you had it what we should do
about it have was transmitted who was
vulnerable to the fatalities what the
case fatality rate is we didn't know
anything so we replaced knowledge that
we could have used with power and panic
and so is one of the inherent problems
that we have fighting
the the bad ideas that would encroach on
our rights that even if you lay out to
people well here's all the things that
government has done wrong although all
the way and here's why it can never work
properly that they always say well that
just means we meet we need more
government that just means we need to
give it more money so it can be bigger
so that we can put more studies out
there to make sure it knows how to do
these things and that answer always sort
of sounds easy and right for people that
aren't really thinking it's much harder
to say to people oh the government
actually should have been scaled way
back on this so we could have let the
professionals deal with it that that
sort of sounds scary to people
especially at a time right now where we
feel like the future is just up in the
air right now
yeah I and I think this speaks to a
little bit of something a principle
that's animated your career in your life
which you had a passion some years ago a
realization that people don't appreciate
freedom they don't have confidence in
freedom that freedom was being attacked
fundamentally and philosophically by
both the left and and and on the right
too and I think you worried about that
you actually asked yourself a very
important question what happens in the
event of a crisis where we need freedom
more than ever and yet we don't have the
intellectual foundations in place
where there's not a cultural love of
this thing we call freedom or an
unwritten much less an understanding of
it what happens then and I think that
was a very interesting perception that
you had you know several years ago that
you really dedicated yourself really
hard to this to this problem and and and
tried your best to do something about it
but I think what we're seeing right now
are the results of a culture that it's
that's that's forgotten the meaning of
freedom that that and one if you lose
that what do you replace it with it's
you replace it with the police state
with yes not good yeah so right now as
we as we sit here all sort of trapped in
our houses trying to figure out what to
do how concerned are you about some of
those basic freedoms that we're talking
about I mean right now the right to
assembly for example we cannot assemble
together you know you can't get ten
people in a room to do anything we had
our our bizarre mayor being nice de
Blasio in New York City say that if he
found temples or churches that were
having any gatherings they could be
permanently closed now again I'm all for
the the six-foot social distancing if
that's what the professionals are
telling us but the idea that we could
permanently close these things and we
can't assemble or our right to free
speech in that we know that even right
now big tech is removing blog posts that
run counter knowledge that's not
necessarily the government stepping in
and doing it but just if we look at just
some of our key freedoms assembly in
speech being the two at the moment how
concerned are you that we're just gonna
sort of put them aside throughout this
and then it'll be six months later and
we'll go oh we had those things yeah I
think anything is possible right now
Dave and anybody who says otherwise
hasn't been paying attention over the
last couple weeks there's no chance so I
looked I read before there before we met
up just now I looked back what I wrote
ran away 27th because I I I wrote an
article warning that the quarantine
power could be used and and and
explained why this is a very very bad
idea but even in that
I imagined something like this that that
the government would set up like
quarantine areas which in fact they have
them and they would come knocking on
your door and grab people out of it
maybe one family at a time and put them
in there in the quarantine area were you
know that they would target maybe
neighborhoods and around everybody up
and put him paddy wagons put him in the
quarantine area but even January 27th I
never imagined the governments of the
world would put everybody under what
amounts to house arrest so the fact that
that this has happened I would say at
this point anything's anything's
possible
I worried because we put out a book last
week called coronavirus and economic
crisis book put out by American
Institute for Economic Research and put
it on Amazon not gonna tell you I was
worried I was worried that Amazon would
take it down so I printed separately
some lots of copies independently with
an independent publisher and started
making it available on the website just
in case we we face massive censorship if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell